what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder and i
know i usually don't post on sundays but
yesterday something very very
interesting happened that i have to talk
about today it looks like we have a toy
leak showing us toby maguire spider-man
for no way home and if this is indeed
legitimate then it definitely confirms
that tobey maguire is going to be in the
film and plus since yesterday pretty
much everybody in the industry that is
kind of known as an insider air quotes
there is basically saying that either
monday or tuesday we should be getting
that spider-man no way home trailer to
the general public not just at cinemacon
so if you're new and you want to stay up
to date be sure to subscribe and hit the
notification bell so you don't miss out
on any of the latest spider-man news so
let's just start with the toy leak and
to my knowledge the original poster of
this on twitter is twitter user at nat
underscore odinson and this user posted
this picture of a toy that shows us toby
maguire's sam raimi's spider-man it's a
titan series action figure and it
definitely is toby maguire spider-man
now there is a little bit of a debate on
whether or not this is actually real the
reason being the action figure to the
right which is of the iron spider suit
of tom holland spider-man on the box it
just says spider-man it doesn't say
spider-man no way home but on the sam
raimi spider-man it does say the full
title spider-man no way home now some
people are saying that because of this
exact thing right here it's fake however
this really isn't that uncommon
especially with the specific titan hero
series and with funko pops here you can
actually see two different packagings
that they used for avengers in-game one
of them simply said avengers and the
other said avengers in-game and they are
both from the titan series here we can
see funko pop do the same exact thing
with tony stark funkos one of them
simply says avengers and the other says
avengers in game so just because the sam
raimi spider-man says no way home on it
doesn't mean that it's fake it actually
kind of means that it's pretty normal of
them to do and to add to it i actually
did spend some time on the internet
searching for other spider-man that may
look like this one trying to see if
somebody simply took an older spider-man
titan hero series figure and tried to
play it off like it's no way home and to
the best of my research abilities i did
not find this exact figure there are
some that kind of look like it but
clearly aren't also not to mention there
is another box underneath at a much
different angle so if somebody were to
photoshop this it would be like the
greatest photoshopper in the planet it
would be a pretty hard photoshop to do
so i'm actually leaning towards this
being more real than fake especially
because everybody should know that i
truly do believe and have been told that
toby maguire and andrew garfield are
going to be in the film if everybody's
wrong i will be completely and utterly
shocked but it's looking like we won't
have to wait that much longer because as
i mentioned in the beginning it does
seem like we are going to be getting our
first teaser monday or tuesday now
yesterday i told you about a report from
lords of the lombok stating that the
trailer would drop monday at 8 am and
this very well could be the case if that
report is accurate but yesterday a lot
of people who are typically in the know
and report scoops often are all saying
that yes the trailer should be coming on
monday or at the very latest tuesday so
i think this is it everybody i think
that teaser is only a day or two away i
don't think we have to wait that much
longer and in the meantime let me know
what you think about this spider-man no
way home toy league don't forget to like
the video and for live updates you can
always follow me on instagram and
twitter and as always thank you all so
much for watching woof